with much laughter over an English
afternoon tea
and of course shoulder cakes
and we forged an instant bond despite
wearing mass and being socially distant
that the opposite ends of a large table
because the like the rest of Europe
were working out how to deal with covid
little did we know
the relationship would grow in such
turbulent times
on the 24th of February 2022
the second invasion of Ukraine began
on the 8th of March 2022 there was
another first for us both
I suspended the House of Commons so that
you could address in Ukrainian through
the screens in our gym
which we still refer to them as zelensky
screams
the atmosphere was electrified you could
hear a pin drop before you came online a
very very rare thing in the House of
Commons
you spelled out the Horrors of the first
13 days of War
your speech was devastating and Powerful
today on the 8th of February 2023 no
deep into the war we are honored that
you have put yourself at risk to address
us and again shine a light on the fact
your country is still fighting for its
survival
this all has been the place of many
great historical events your presence
here today adds another to them
the war as you know better than any of
us has lasted for nearly a year
as you told us last year
this is a war Ukraine did not start and
did not want
but it is a war you have had to fight
and our commitment to support you and
your people has not wavered
I was considering
what could be said at this important
occasion I thought back to the 1990s
then we hoped that all countries that
emerged from the former Soviet Union
could secure freedom and prosperity
there was a moment of Hope over that
time and we knew it would be a long time
that each country could choose its own
destiny
it is a tragedy that Ukraine's efforts
to bring freedom prosperity to its
people has been met with war and death
last year building on our friendship I
welcome your wife
madame salenska to Parliament to Alton
deliberately a provocative exhibition
I wanted to ensure the experience of
your people is kept at the Forefront of
our minds I do not believe any of us in
this room were complacent about the
reality of conflict
but those displays shocked us the images
stayed with us
they brought home the horrors of War
Horrors inflicted on your people
Fighters civilians alike Horrors which
cannot be avoided or denied
I applaud Ukraine's refusal to forget
what is you and your people are fighting
for
in the words of the European Eurovision
winners Kyle Russia Orchestra they said
I always find my way home
even if all roads are destroyed
fight of your country is not fight
simply fighting for territory it is a
fight for home and for an idea
the endurance of the people
the people of Ukraine honors those
ideals the refusal to allow War to
destroy the humanity honors their ideals
lost right quite rightly last year you
said
ukrainians have become big over the 13
days of this war you have become even
bigger in your determination not just to
fight for your country but to stand by
the ideals you are fighting for
we'll not give up on those ideas we'll
continue to support you against that
Russian aggressor
and I pledge here today in front of all
of you to all I come to keep the plight
of you creating the spotlight
later this year the UK and Ukraine will
be United in music
but we will always be United in our
unwavering belief in the power of
democracy schlava Ukraine Mr President
please
[Applause]
foreign
thank you so much
the people
of them United Kingdom and their
honorable Representatives
all the people of England and Scotland
of Wales and Northern Ireland
of all the lands which have been home to
Brave Souls since Europe came into
existence
I have come here and stand before you
on behalf of the Brave
on behalf of our Warriors who are now in
the trenches under enemy artillery fire
on behalf of our ear Gunners and every
defender of this guy who protects
Ukraine against enemy aircrafts and
missiles
on behalf of our 10th command who fight
to restore our Ukrainian borders on
behalf of our conscripts who are being
trained now including here in Britain
thank you Britain
[Applause]
and who will be then deployed to the
front line
skilled equipped and eager to win
on behalf of every father and every
mother who are waiting for their Brave
sons and brave daughters back home from
the war
Mr Speaker
ah
you may I think well remember as roughly
more than two years
two years ago we met with you here in
Parliament great honor was to me and we
I remember we enjoyed
T
we talked of course
I talked a lot about our people and our
about our countries throughout the
British and Ukrainian political
traditions
Mr Prime Minister
Rishi when we had our meeting earlier
today and I said to you that I would
tell you I will tell a story in my
address to the Parliament and a story
about my feelings on my first visit to
London
as as president in Autumn 2020
the program was packed Royal highnesses
William and Catherine and
Buckingham Palace and aircraft carrier
of the royal Navy
the Westminster of course Downing Street
and of course
the war rooms
and there
in the war room
their famous churches
on chair and a guide and the guide
smiled and offered me to sit down
on this I'm sure from which were others
have been given
and he asked me
how did I feel
and I said that I certainly
felt something
but it is only now
that I know what the feeling was
and all ukrainians know it perfectly
well too
it is the feeling of how bravering takes
you through the most unimaginable
hardships to finally reward you with
victory
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen I thank you for
your bravery thank you very much from
all
from all of us yes please
that is for you all Applause for you
London has stood with cave since day one
from the first seconds and minutes of
the full-scale war
Great Britain you extended your helping
hand when the world had not yet come to
understand how to react
[Music]
Boris
you go to others United when it seemed
absolutely absolutely impossible thank
you
[Applause]
all of you you all showed your greet and
character back then strong British
character
you didn't compromise Ukraine
and hence you didn't compromise your
ideas and thus you didn't compromise the
spirit of this great Islands thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you
and of course of course everybody
understands that our countries knew
absolutely different times our Nations
defended freedom in the second world war
the the Iron Curtain divided us our
people went through crisis and grows
through
inflation and periods of social losses
and social gains it was tough but we
always found strengths and stamina to
move ahead and Achieve results
this is the Bedrock of our land and your
traditions ukrainians and Brits defeated
the fear of war and had the time to
enjoy peace
no matter
what we
encountered on
different different stages of our of our
endure formidable history and you you
and us
and the whole mankind achieved similar
result evil lost
evil lost
we will always come out on top of evil
these lies at the core of of our but
also your traditions
however the Horizon never stays clear
for a while once the old evil is
defeated
the new one is attempting to rise its
head
do you have a feeling that the evil will
crumble once again
I can see
in your eyes now we think the same way
as you do we know Freedom will win
[Applause]
we know
we know Russia will lose
and we we really know the victory the
victory will change the world and this
will be a change that the world has long
needed
the United Kingdom
is marching with us towards the most I
think the most important victory of our
lifetime it will be a victory over the
weary idea of the war
after we went together any aggressor it
doesn't matter big or small will know
what awaits him if he attacks
International order
any aggressor
any aggressor who will try to push the
bandaras by force who will inflict
destruction and Death on other peoples
who will try to endure his dictatorship
and the ex at the expense of other
people's blood in criminal and
unprovoked Wars as the Kremlin does any
aggressor is going to lose
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen we have already
achieved remarkable results and we must
make every effort to turn our
achievements into the foundations of the
future Global Security security
architecture the world the world needs
your leadership Britain just as it needs
Ukrainian bravery
foreign
the full-scale animation began
we together with you Rhythm and United
States and other allies formed a true
Coalition of France that is very
important you were among those very few
who had helped before The large-scale
Invasion began exactly as it will be
necessary every time in the future to
prevent aggression from happening
your help was preventive we must take
this
principles of preventive Aid to those
who are threatened with aggression and
preventive sanctions again those who
threaten aggressive as basic principles
of the world enter War policy we created
a coalition of and low
thank you
of Enloe and Javelin that stopped the
advance of the Russian army from the
first day of the invasion
foreign
defense which allow us to save the lives
of our children of our people of our
civilians our women our elderly and our
cities from Russia from Russian
atrocious occupation and missile Terror
we put together a powerful sanction
coalition
and your leadership is protecting
International legal order through
sanctions against a terrorist State
cannot be questioned
and we have to steadily to steadily
continue along this way until Russia is
deprived
of any possibility to finance the war
most importantly
together with a G7 we brought about a
coalition of values
a coalition that protects the rule-based
wall to other and human rights
a coalition that will work in such a way
that over time there will simply be no
gray areas in the world in which human
life doesn't matter
in order for it to be so there must be
Justice
anyone who invests in Terror
must be held accountable
anyone anyone who invests in violence
must compensate those who have suffered
from Terror
Terror aggression or or other forms of
State violence
our proposals for the creation of the
special
Tribunal for the crime of Russian
aggression against Ukraine and special
compensation mechanism which will
compensate War losses at the expense of
Russian assets are based on such on such
principles
Justice is one of ten
elements of the peace formula proposed
by Ukraine and supported by Britain I
thank you for your Readiness to invoke
the formula thank you prime minister
thank you very much
as I
as I already mentioned
your grand soldiers are being trained in
Britain in particular to operate
Challengers
your
main battle tanks and I it's a tank
Coalition in action
and I thank you
thank you Rishi
thank you very much for this powerful
defensive step
for tank assistance thank you the
Coalition of long-range missiles is the
latest of all it will allow us to make
the evil
evil completely retrieved from our
country by destroying its headways deep
in the occupied territories
and it's not just
I'm not speaking just about weapons we
prove together that the world truly
helps those who are brave in defending
freedom
and thus paves paves the way for a new
history
a history of the world
history of the world that knows how to
be quick in help
who knows how to be effective in defense
who knows how to remain principled in
dark hours
who implements its treaties and
Arrangements in good faith
who does not allow
perpetrators to enjoy
to enjoy
immunity who knows how to overcome veto
when it's abused who knows no fear and
who knows how to win
this shall be
then you reality
of the Free World I'm sure
however evil evil evil is still
is still around around today and the
battle continues yes we know
how it's going
to end and how we are going to feel on
the day Victory comes every day we
continue to pay to pay with lives
pain and tears
of bringing
for bringing Victory closing
with the lives of our
of our people our heroes whom we
loose
in battles
with the lives of Our Heroes
who take life
and death risks every day to save as
many of our soldiers and civilians as
possible
and today
I will have the honor
to be received by his majesty the king
it will be a truly special moment
ah for me
for our country
and in particular because I will convey
to him from all the
all the ukrainians the wars of gratitude
for the support his majesty showed to
them when he was still the Prince of
Wales
and I also intend to tell him something
that is I think that is very very
important not only for the future of
Ukraine but also for the future of
Europe in Britain
in Britain the king
is a near Force pilot
and in Ukraine today
every year Force pilate is a king
[Applause]
for us just just for us
for our families
because they are so few
they are so
precious
that we the Servants of our Kings
do everything possible and impossible to
make the world provide us with modern
planes
to empower and protect pilots who will
be protecting us
and I am proud of our Air Force
and I brought a present
from them
to you Great Britain
yes please open place
yes
to the speaker yes
I will
[Applause]
it's it's I
foreign
real Ukrainian pilot he is one of our
most successful
Aces and he's one of our Kings
and the writing on the helmet reads
we have freedom give us Wings to protect
it
[Applause]
I trust I trust this symbol will help us
for our next coalition
Coalition of the planes and I appeal to
you and the world was simple and yet
most important words
combat aircrafts for Ukraine
wings for freedom
Great Britain
you and us both struggle for peace but
instead of we are forced to face the
range that seeks to deprive us of peace
and everything else that is valuable in
life unfortunately it is in human nature
to allow evil
mature
it then stands up against humanity
it then destroys
and kills it launches aggressions and
breaks people's lives you and us
have already fought together again
against such evil
you and us already
have the experience of defeating the
evil that is generated by human nature
I'm not saying there will be there will
be no more Wars after the war ends no it
is impossible to completely erase evil
from Human Nature
yet it is in our power to guarantee with
words and deeds that the light side of
human nature will prevail
decide you and us share
and distance above anything else
thank you
for your attention
for your support
and living
a British Parliament two years ago I
thanked you
for delicious English tea
and I will be living
the parliament today
thanking all of you in advance
for powerful English planes
[Applause]
by the way it's almost five o'clock
God bless Great Britain and long
long live
the king
solo green
[Applause]
foreign
for being with us today and for the
powerful address that you have just
given
The Bravery resilience and fortitude of
you and your people is a great example
to all
Mr President this Great Hall
in which we stand
with its walls first built more than 900
years ago
has seen many speeches from great and
iconic readers
today's event
will weave a new panel in that rich
tapestry of History thank you
Westminster Hall is at the core
of the National Life of our country
and has played a prominent role in the
development of our judicial system and
our parliamentary democracy
but the story of this whole is also a
tale of resilience and of remaining
steadfast in the face of disaster
while fire raged around this site in
destroying our old Parliament
Westminster Hall stood proud
when during the second World War
bombs rent on London
Westminster Hall remained largely
undamaged
stoic in the face of great Pearl
this Hall reminds us that in the face of
Challenge and conflict symbols of our
national identity and sovereignty will
endure
giving powerful and visible hope to our
peoples during times of tribulation
in the same way the endurance of your
government and its institutions in the
midst of a colossal threat to Ukraine
continues to inspire your population and
millions more beyond your borders
endurance and inspiration rests in large
part upon the leadership that you have
demonstrated since your country was
forced into this terrible conflict
Mr President a conflict which you did
not choose
effective leadership demands the ability
to respond to unpredictable challenges
Mr President
in the extraordinary situation in which
you were placed visibility was essential
in testing times leaders must be visible
to their people
and from the outset last February when
bombs were falling on Kiev you were
visible
broadcasting from the streets of your
capital
you reassured ukrainians and indeed the
world of the determination of your
government in the face of violent
aggression
your leadership has been steadfast
in the early days of this conflict
some suggested that the Ukrainian state
could not withstand the Russian threat
and at the war would quickly end
in one of your broadcasts during the
early bombardment
you famously said we are all here
you did not leave
you showed the world
that your government was still at work
in cave
and was fully committed to the defense
of Ukraine
your people have followed this example
with an inspirational display of Bravery
Vision has also characterized your
leadership
you have not only expressed your belief
in the continuing ability of ukrainians
to withstand aggression
but have embodied that belief
offering hope of our reconstructed
Ukraine playing its full part in the
future of Europe
that vision
will continue to sustain you and your
people in the difficult times ahead
finally
a great leader never gives up
selflessness and bringing people
together
are the essence of leadership
Mr Speaker Mr President you exemplify
these qualities in abundance
we salute
your determination
your resilience
your courage
so let me thank you once again Mr
President for your visit today
we wish you and the Ukrainian people
success
strength and fortitude
You are not alone in this struggle
this Parliament and indeed the country
stands with you in solidarity as you
continue this Noble fight
thank you for your visit
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
[Applause]